on va en parler tout de suite avec
benoît martin il est secrétaire
départemental cgt
benoît martin bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
comment a été accueillie la suspension
de la réforme des retraites annoncée
hier soir par emmanuel macron ça faisait
partie de son discours aussi cependant
oui tout à fait et bien écoutez nous
félicitant que ce projet doit soit
suspendu de même que nous nous
félicitons que d'autres mesures seraient
suspendus comme par exemple
l'application de l'assurance chômage qui
devait survenir 1er avril ainsi que les
expulsions locatives qui elle aussi un
sont suspendus donc il ya un certain
nombre de mesures
et puis également la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris qui est suspendu
donc de nous félicitons de de ces
mesures qui sont en sage raisonnable
mais évidemment la priorité c'est bel et
bien d'éradiquer le grand navire russe
pendant ce temps et bien entendu à cette
priorité
aujourd'hui néanmoins une fois que cette
crise sanitaire sera passée pensez vous
que le débat demandé par la cgt sur la
réforme des retraites pourra se faire
alors écoutez nous pour l'instant on
avait par exemple prévu d'organiser une
contre conférence de financement le 24
mars
évidemment nous ne le ferons pas nous
avions prévu de manifester de faire
grève le 31 mars ne le feront pas non
plus aimé donc il faudra après que le
49-3 car on n'oublie pas qu'il ya un 49
3 qui a été dégainée et je pense qu'une
des sanctions pour le gouvernement a été
le résultat des élections municipales où
l ère même a fait de très mauvais
résultats
donc on a beau être dans une anse perdre
une seconde solidarité de toute la
nation de tous les travailleurs de tous
les citoyens pour éradiquer
un virus il n'empêche que cette
suspension du temps social ne durera pas
éternellement et qu'ensuite nous
demanderons bel et bien parce que le
retrait du projet de loi sur les
retraites bien entendu au delà de la
suspension alors justement aujourd'hui à
vous rappeler ce contexte très
particulier un contexte inédit en tant
que secrétaire départemental de la cgt
quel est votre message à vous
aujourd'hui aux travailleurs et bien le
message c'est de respecter les consignes
données par l'état car emmanuel macron à
endosser une nouvelle casquette depuis
quelques jours et il est redevenu chef
de l'état et non plus chef dé la finance
et du patronat
donc il faut respecter ses consignes et
puis il faut continuer à faire du
syndicalisme dans les conditions
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire veiller à la
sécurité et à l'hygiène aux conditions
de travail et en tant que syndicaliste
notre rôle n'est pas suspendue pendant
cette crise sanitaire
au contraire nous avons un rôle
particulier à jouer et je sais que par
exemple aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
saint-antoine il y avait un droit d'
alerte qui a été déclenchée parce que je
dois y ait des problèmes en termes de
fourniture de matériel élémentaire sûr
hélas la sécurité des agents
hospitaliers
nous sommes en contact aussi avec les
crèches parisiennes avec les écoles
parisiennes qui sont ouverts au niveau
des crèches
bien que 34 qui sont ouvertes
c'est-à-dire à peine 10% mais c'est
nécessaire pour accueillir les enfants
de personnel hospitalier donc tout ça
fonctionne à peu près mais il ya quand
même des choses à regarder de très près
surtout qu'on n'est pas encore au pic au
niveau de l'épidémie
justement sur la situation des hôpitaux
en tant que secrétaire départemental de
la cgt
vous avez des retours alarmant vous
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
quelle est votre position aujourd'hui ah
oui c'est très tendu cette crise du
grenat virus est un vrai révélateur
depuis des années mais même des dizaines
d'années un depuis madame bachelot
ensuite on a eu madame touraine
bizarre mais il ya eu des
restructurations hospitalières qui ont
toujours dégradé un peu plus un des
camps dire le service public hospitalier
des fermetures de lits de moins en moins
de lits de moins en moins d'hôpitaux de
moins en moins de personnel de moins en
moins de moyens et on voit bien que là
et bien c'est extrêmement tendue dans
les hôpitaux parisiens de l'ap-hp il
manque du monde ils montrent que du
matériel il manque des lits et ça va là
on va passer vraiment en phase critique
merci beaucoup benoît martin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur rt
frange rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental de la cgt
je voulais également ajouter juste un
petit quizz les ans près alesi le matin
et tous les emplois précaires les
intérimaires etc
là il ya vraiment une alerte extrêmement
importante aussi que je donne car les
personnes les plus fragiles ou fin de
leur contrat de travail risque vraiment
d'être impactée plus que les autres
voilà on a entendu votre attention
particulière aux personnes les plus
fragiles
en ce temps de confinement liés à
l'épidémie et du coronavirus merci
benoît martin